[Music]
it is my pleasure today to host this
conversation with Shafi goldwasser who
has recently taken over as a scientific
director of the simons stood for theory
of computing at Berkeley in addition to
this very important role Shafi is a
professor of computer science at
Berkeley MIT and the Weizmann Institute
in Israel Shafi is an exceptional leader
in the field today with notable
contributions that have had lasting
impact
she's the co-inventor of the idea of
probabilistic encryption and zero
knowledge proves two central ingredients
in her quest to establish a sound
foundation for modern cryptography
she's also founder of the fields of pro
listicle checkable proves properly
testing proof delegation and you name it
additionally she is noted for building
bridges between areas within and outside
the theory of computing including
connections to number theory with the
first algorithm for certifying prime
allottee of numbers and connecting the
aforementioned probabilistically
checkable proofs to the approximability
of optimization problems a field that
has revolutionized communitarian
optimization today all this work and no
fun well actually she got a few awards
during this period which must have been
pretty nice most notably she's the
winner of the ACM Turing award this is
the highest award in the field of
computer science other awards that she
has won include the Benjamin Franklin
price the Immanuel a puree award she's a
member of the National Academies in the
US in Russia and in her home state of
Israel and two awards that I'd like to
mention in addition are the grace Murray
hopper award and the ACM Athena award
where her presence elevates the
visibility of excellent work done by
women in the field despite the very many
challenges so in our conversation today
I hope we'll hear a little bit about her
explorations in the field of computer
science and about the community the
awards and the challenges so happy
looking forward should talk to you thank
you for this very kind introduction
so must say I mean it was very
gratifying writing these few paragraphs
and I was quite impressed that I could
compress it down to just that much so
all right so let's start with the
beginning so how did you get to become a
computer scientist tell us a little bit
about how you you know how you started
and got into this field okay so I began
as a undergraduate student at Carnegie
Mellon and but even to go to Carnegie
Mellon was somewhat accidental I was a
high school student in Israel I was
always pretty good in science and math
and I somehow arrived to Carnegie Mellon
because my brother was a student I was
good at science were you doing computer
science at Carnegie Mellon no I was
doing applied math in fact there was no
undergraduate in computer science at the
time there was a concentration or focus
in computer science and after a couple
of years in applied math I took a
computer science course algorithms and
data structures and then it's sort of
one thing led to the other area I came
to Berkeley as a graduate student and I
kind of fell in love with fear of
computing and start working on it was
that one moment where you felt was it
that Carnegie Mellon was it at Berkeley
when you felt this is really the field
that you want to be in it was gradual
maybe so the question is what is the
field so when I was an undergraduate
student in Carnegie Mellon I think this
whole idea of programming and writing
programs and designing algorithms and
then they actually you execute them and
you get results it was fascinating I've
never seen a computer before I was a
junior probably trying college and the
computer science problems you know the
discrete math I was enjoyable but the
truth is that the course that I probably
enjoyed most as an undergraduate was a
course on artificial intelligence that
whole idea that a particular aspect of
artificial intelligence that I was drawn
to was had to do with linguistics at the
time I remember there was a project for
generating poetry automatic
and I wrote this program he generated
these horrible poems were dramatically
correct okay I think that was the end of
my career
very important so so that was artificial
intelligence right and then that made it
was kind of obvious that I would go and
study computer science in graduate
school but when I came to Berkeley I
actually didn't study artificial
intelligence a in fact I worked with
Manuel Blum was a theorist and I did
work in theory with in theory the course
that really kind of clinched it for me
was a course in Manuel Blum taught okay
right so that probably brings us to some
of your early works so from now on I'd
like you to explain to us in some depth
some of your works I mean I reeled off
some names probabilistic encryption zero
knowledge you can pick and choose though
I would love to start with your first
result which one was that the first
result that I think really is worth
talking about yeah
so the first result that I think is
worth talking about is this idea of how
to encrypt a single bit so when we I
took this class woman well Blum it was a
class on computational number theory
which is essentially how to solve
problems in number theory using
algorithms to solve them quickly define
certificates short certificates for
something being a prying or being
composite and one of the interesting
parts of the class or the last few
lectures where he gave some lectures
relevant to modern cryptography so the
time Watto cryptography was about two or
three papers it's public key
cryptography by D F a hell man it was a
reverse Shamir and Adleman paper and
Manuel asked this very simple question
how do you toss a coin over the
telephone so somehow that what was
interesting about the questions many
things but one of them was that there
was a single bit answer which was the
value of the coin so let me poke a
little bit into this question okay toss
a coin over the phone so we want to talk
to each other over the phone and at the
end we want to say is it heads or tails
that's right so we are opposing parties
okay hey you know you want heads and I
want tails and we have no way to
communicate except by sending messages
through
so this is talking over the phone and
the question is how are you going to do
that there's no physical coin that I can
toss and tell you the valley because you
don't believe me so how can we emulate
using message exchange the effect that
at the end there is a unbiased bit at
least 50% heads 50% tails so 50% heads
and tails would be too good to be true
okay it would be an outcome such that
neither one of us would have a
noticeable effect on making it either
heads or tails a noticeable effect means
within a pono amount of time okay sounds
good okay so tell us motor okay so in
terms of my result a so then at that
time encryption or probably key
cryptography or encryption based on
number theory really they it was RSA was
a veterinarian animal scheme where you
encrypt messages and it's sort of
inherent in that scheme is that the
messages have to be you know large in a
sense because otherwise is it two
different deterministic encryption
scheme where for every message is a
single way to encrypt it okay so you
know an obvious question that came up at
that time was how much partial
information is hidden about the message
from its encryption and the reason why
that came up is because people were
using encryption in order to play card
games or at least it was a paper
beautiful paper by Shamir and Adleman
called how to play him into poker and
the question there was you somehow the
idea was you encrypt the cards and you
have a way to deal cards to each other
but they didn't address the question
what about leaking partial information
by the card from its encryption it
should be extremely important in a card
game right so it distilled so the
question was how we're going to encrypt
cards in a way that would hide all
partial information and the crux of that
question is really how do you encrypt a
single bit so how do you cut toss a coin
over the phone so how the toss a coin is
a value is it an unbiased coin it could
be 0 or 1 and you won 50/50 here you
actually have either a 0 or 1 anyone
encrypted okay of course if you could do
that you could also toss a coin how is
that because suppose the way we would
not want to define encrypting 0 & 1 is
that you won't be able to tell better
than 5050 where they encrypted a 0 or 1
then what I could do if we're trying to
toss a coin is I would toss a coin maybe
to decide whether I'm going to encrypt
heads or tails so
might be zero-tails might be one then i
encrypt the value of the coin and send
it to you if the encryption was so
strong that you can't tell apart where
they encrypted heads or tails now you
make a guess but I'm but you're now
committed to so I'm committed exactly
you make a guess if you guess the right
value then I open it up then we you win
if you guess the wrong value I win
I see so okay great okay yeah so the in
any case for the first result there was
how do we encrypt a single bit yeah and
I think that probably in terms of sort
of research breakthrough hey that's
probably the first that I can remember
one of the ones I'm most attached to
maybe cuz it's the first and that was to
find a problem a yes/no question a
computational problem which seems to be
difficult to decide better than 50 50 50
okay and in addition that you can
generate instances where the answer is
yes and instances for there no and this
immediately leads to a way to encrypt a
single bit because you come up with an
instance with the answer is yes if you
only encrypt a zero you come up with an
instance when the answer is no one want
to encrypt the one now since it's hard
to distinguish whether the solution is
yes or no the adversary when I send you
the instance am I trying to encrypt a
bit too you can't tell whether it's yes
or no the only thing that still remains
to be understood is how do you know
whether the answer is yes or no so
eventually you want to convince me that
this is what you did so so actually for
encrypting a single bit the problem that
that I'm talking about is called
deciding with the numbers quadratic
residue or quadratic non residue mod a
composite number and if you know the
factorization of this composite number
you can actually tell oh I see so this
is one of those problems where if you
knew how to factor numbers nothing would
be no secrets would be hidden exact but
on the other hand assuming that
factoring is hard and maybe a few more
things yeah you could guarantee that
this one bit was encrypted and I would
not know what it is till you tell me
what was right in fact what you assume
is the deciding where the number is a
square the quadratic residue a quadratic
non residue is hard a in some worst-case
sense and what we show this is work with
Silvio is that if then it's not only
case but there's a worse case than
random okay so fandom reduction so it
seems like many ideas went into your
very first paper or the first time that
you're willing to talk about it yeah I
should mention that this is probably one
of the works that was cited in the
Turing award citation it's pretty
impressive for course you know for
outcome of a course project one could
say was that course project it was just
that he really managed to explain to us
or get through this excitement about how
number theory and the difficulty of
certain problems in number theory and
the ease of other problems so here are
the difficulties of factoring but the
ease of generating these quadratic
visitors and non residues or the ease of
solving it when you do know in the
factorization whether something is a
quadratic residue or not you managed to
somehow really transmit this excitement
that these problems are can be the
foundation for solving some real-world
phenomena like sending a message like
tossing a coin it's amazing so I mean
it's a sensational I do want to talk to
you about your feelings as a student
while you were here but maybe we'll get
to that in a few minutes sure do want
you to tell us a little bit about your
other favorite results maybe hey let me
let me start since you started with your
favorite my favorite okay what would
have probably also been probably the
encryption my second favorite result is
of course zero knowledge tell us what is
zero knowledge okay I'll tell you about
the or not within in terms of favorites
I will tell you about my malady testing
was certified so the idea is the
following that again if you want to link
it to cryptography just so that we have
some sort of motivation in fact let's
link it to mental poker so remember I
said there's this game you want to play
poker
uh-huh the two of us are over the
Internet or over the phone and we need a
way to have a deck of cards
so that would be emulated by encrypting
a bunch of there's a the name of a card
you encrypting it there's like 52 cards
and then there's some way to deal cards
to each other to take them out of the
deck to do whatever poker rules of the
game right dictate and
we had a protocol so in that original
paper and the only way that we could
sort of verify at the end of the game
that the game was played correctly was
that we in some sense opened up all the
cards and we showed that everybody
followed the rules right so know what
the dealer is not dealing the same card
twice right you didn't just choose all
the red cards for himself right so
there's no really dealer but that
somehow that we follow the protocol the
two of us playing and at the end
somebody wins somebody loses in order to
determine who won and lost and whether
we follow that we have to open
everything up now in a real poker game
you might know what it described your
strategy right so then the question was
how am i can I prove to you that I
follow the rules uh-huh
without actually showing you what I did
right so you don't want to say why you
get another card why you didn't decline
but at the end you want to prove you
have the winning cards I want to prove
there have the winning cards or we want
to just determine that I won the game
that you won the game so we don't even
you don't even reveal the cards maybe
that's right it's not clear when you are
going to bid more when you're not going
to bid more you don't want to tell me
anything about when you take when you're
gambling when you're not right you just
want to at the end say okay look when
you've decided here's proof that I won
the game all right and in fact the poker
is just an example think about a more
bizarre game that we don't even know how
to play with a dick in this game I may
be the the deciding who wins or loses is
if the I don't know exclusive or of my
car cards that are encrypted and
and your cards represented as binary
strings and so forth equals two to zero
okay so that's another game complicated
my information all your cards yeah
there's some complicated winning
function perhaps not even that we don't
we can define the rules but we don't
know how they implement it even with
some physical device even if we had a
deck if you know if we had a cubes or
coins or whatever maybe we don't know
actually how to physically realize the
game that we could write down the rules
on paper right okay so the question was
how do I prove to you that I followed
those rules without actually showing you
exactly all the steps that I took just
like in the mental a game meant a poker
game example and zero knowledge if you
want to think about it is a way to do so
I'm able to prove to you the correctness
of a statement without giving you the
full proof and you still will believe it
and the correctness of the statement
here is that I won the game what did I
follow the rules so you started with
maybe a game like poker how to play it
maybe you had some Geographic
transaction and you said okay I could
make this secure without revealing
anything about my identity other than to
reveal that I'm an authorized user maybe
winning the games but it is escalated
into something very general right it was
no longer anything about cryptography it
was no more anything about secure
transactions on the Internet it was not
about playing for games over the phone
zero knowledge actually covers
everything today at what moment did you
realize you were going from the problems
that you were looking at to everything
um did it come as a surprise so there's
there's a there's an implicit notion of
a proof here right where I'm trying to
prove to you some fact so there is
already approver who would be me
there's a verifier would be you who's
verifying whether the proof is correct
right and there's some extra ingredients
in addition to a classical proof where
we can interact back and forth so in a
classical proof right I'll just write
down the proof and you would read it a
so we can interact back and forth
we may be able to toss coins so the kind
of questions you're gonna ask me you we
can think of your messages as questions
to me that I as approver I'm going to
answer and if I didn't if I knew all
your questions in advance we could just
write it down but if you're tossing
coins ask me questions that means that
it we might neccessity an interaction so
all these ingredients okay right which
the example of poker is what sort of
brought us in that direction
right a really describes our a more
generalized view of what a proof is
right where it's a process where one
person is has the ability to prove a
statement to another and yet at the end
the verifier would be able to verify
with high probability that the same is
correct
and yet won't be able to prove it to a
third party right and that's the
generality the third is right in fact
your your ventures into what proofs of
proofs have been have been quite well
documented
I think interactive proofs started in
the same paper you talked about multi
proven interactive proofs and later
works yeah what probably Stickley
checkable proofs and even later works
and now you're talking about proofs in
delegation so there is this remarkable
role that proofs and it's not just that
you're writing proofs of theorems that
you know you're actually talking about
us proving things to others this seems
to be an ongoing theme tell us a few
maybe a little bit more about the
highlights over here was there okay an
interesting interactive proof that
you're aware of or in terms of the
beginning in terms of the beginning the
middle anytime yeah right so in the
beginning there was a proof that Manuel
was very interested in Monroe Blum and
that was how to prove that a number is a
composite number so okay that is product
of two primes versus three primes so
those are those are both cases which are
hard to it's hard to factor so how do
you even convince it it's a number as a
factor of two versus three is unclear so
that was kind of one of the first
examples of an interactive proof but I
want to kind of refer to something else
you
about that in all these examples that
you mentioned interactive proofs multi
proven interactive proofs pcps
a there is a notion of someone who's
verifying uh-huh and then there's a
notion of someone or something that we
call the proof right so in this in the
interactive proof there's a we won't it
we kind of an attempt for morphus eyes
the prover must wait order it's an
algorithm here henceforth that's a word
with an algorithm that receives messages
and since it sends messages and it a
sorry so I'm the proof you're the
verifier I we're sending messages back
and forth I'm an algorithm you were
maybe a weaker algorithm because I'm
able to prove something to you right
which you might not know because you're
computationally weaker or because I have
some witness to a statement which you
were right you don't have in the multi
prover setting which came up because
zero knowledge essentially it was proved
in a paper by Goethe off McCallion
victor said that if one-way functions
exist everything that has a proof has
also a zero knowledge proof pricey but
they had an assumption if one-way
functions exist and I I was visiting
Hebrew University in a sabbatical and I
was challenged is there anything else to
prove in cryptography a once we know
this that everything can be done in zero
knowledge and sort of to answer that
challenge it was well wouldn't be nice
to prove it without assumptions right
right but we can't actually we don't
know how to prove it without assumptions
and so the solution to that challenge
was to come up with a different proof
model so rather than think about a
single proved er let's think about two
Cooper's I see and they are both of them
are they've maybe it's a cold joint
paper they know a proof and now they're
trying to convince me that the proof is
correct again they want to do it there
in zero knowledge we're gonna put them
sort of separate in separate room in
separate rooms like with you know cut
and up resist a little bit let's say the
two of them committed a crime crime is
they're trying to cheat me the proof is
not correct and I want to catch new and
if I don't know and the verify yeah
that's right
before I was the prover
I'm the verifier there are these two
approvers and I'm gonna interrogate them
perhaps I'm gonna use the answer of one
to check against the answer of the other
if they are consistent then this is good
okay then this is going okay good and so
this this evolution has led us to
remarkable discoveries they have really
changed the shape of the field can you
tell us a little bit about your role for
example in the in the ability of
interactive proofs to do things in the
ability of multiple proven interactive
proves to the things you found what they
could do and what they could not do this
led you to some very interesting
discoveries also right now I think that
my role probably what I'm best at in my
role in this evolution is to come up
with or point to these different models
you know the single over so the multi
prover and to see connections also
between these proof systems and another
so for example in in the connection to
harness approximation you are thinking
of interpretation of a multi prove er
proof system as a graph so you sort of
think about the strategy of the proofs
what was approver a as a node in a graph
and two strategies are consistent a then
there might be an edge between them if
they're inconsistent there is no edge
that defines some sort of graph and
right you can think of a click of this
graph as essentially a full strategy of
approver so you drifted from a problem
in cryptography to a question about
logic interaction and proofs and then
you now have a problem in combinatorics
and you're trying to find big cliques
and graphs that's right and I'm not the
big the size of the clique of the graph
is related to the probability that there
is a strategy to convince the verifier
to accept and if there's a small clique
and there's this it's the probability
that there is a strategy it's small more
so in some sense the strategies is
associated with probability so so these
have been remarkable discoveries you
also mentioned primarily testing what do
you want to say about that right
yeah so the course of mine well that
sort of started my love of cryptography
in love of number theory focused on
several problems in number theory and
the first one or maybe the most basic
one was how do you tell efficiently that
a number is prime a very basic question
and number theory it's a very basic
question number theory and if you had
all the time in the world there's no
problem you just try to divide numbers
but can you do it efficiently what are
you doing in poem and logarithmic in the
number of bits to write down the prime
and now we know you can a but for a long
time the only way we knew how to do that
with the toss coins okay so the question
that I work with the stuffing coins do
too so if a number is a prime so the
idea was that there's essentially
there's evidence to be found they
conclusive conclusive evidence that a
number is is composite it's not a price
it's not a prime okay and with that it
says that a number is a prime it could
actually be a composite because you have
evidence okay so it's it's not quite the
same but if I say 51 is not a prime I
can say this is 3 times 17 that
certainly tells me convinces everybody
who can verify this that this is not a
prime but how do you prove that some
other number I don't know maybe 53 is a
prime and you want to come up with some
way of convincing me okay all right so I
just want to say that there is a
difference between an algorithm and a
proof right so an algorithm might
probably stick algorithm a you run it
that's where the input is a number you
see the prime or composite you're
running at the end it says to you the
conclusion prime composite and these
Monte Carlo prophecy algorithms when you
look at the answer you say I believe it
because with very high probability over
the coin tosses he would have given me
the correct answer right a that's
different from an algorithm that at the
end produces a proof of it's a that you
can actually verify 100% the numbers
composite or proof that you can verify
100% of the numbers prime so the
algorithm could have been randomized
could be doing anything
in the middle where at the end whatever
it produces is going to be certificate
it's exactly in that it was the work
that I with a joke alien who was a
graduate student of mine then and that
we came up with primarily proving
algorithm where not only that you run
the algorithm and at the end you are
fairly confident it's correct but it
actually you toss coins to look for
proof that can be verified 100% that the
number is prime and he was using
elliptic curves theer elliptic curves
and the theory of elliptic curves was
pretty I remember trying to read this
paper as a graduate student it was
pretty intimidating I must say this was
traverse this long into the field of
number theory and pretty much a pretty
strong adventure for you to to get into
this one but yeah but there's always so
in a way to not always but certainly in
that paperweight to abstract what is
this disease elliptic curves they're
beautiful so they gives you some sort of
group structure on points and somehow
you can relate the order of a point to
where they're you know when you're a
opposite of it's a prime yeah okay
fantastic so so tell us about one more
research theme that you liked a lot yeah
perhaps another research theme which is
sort of also early on is a research
thing with property testing so property
testing actually was started by you know
in the context of in the context of
algebra right testing you and will need
testing linearity testing low degree
polynomials where the function is a low
degree polynomial and these were
beautiful notions fail to break and then
they didn't go to a can done a Ron and I
were talking about this and somehow it
came up what about why should properly
testing be only of algebraic objects how
about combinatorial objects surprised
say that you have a graph and you'd like
to know where this graph is can be
colored with K colors or is it far from
being colorable with K Karla's or many
other questions you could ask about
graphs and you want to test this
property so what's the difference
between testing this property and
actually deciding
the difference is really that you not
allowed to in a sense look at the entire
graph you can only sample it and at the
same time you're relaxing sort of what
is required right so I feel this the
same kind of same relationship and we've
talked about things it was in a very
narrow context algebra we're gonna you
know be a very specific problem and you
went again to this complete abstract
generality take any property and we want
to test it and you had some notable
successes there so I say yeah I mean to
me it was very inspiring to see how you
can actually switch perspectives and
then suddenly come up with so many
interesting questions so I must say that
often these things happen in a way that
it's very hard to remember or maybe you
can remember it but it's very hard to
understand where the inspiration comes
from that's true
yeah so tell us generally about your
research philosophy how do you attack a
question see do you say this is the
problem to be solved and I will work on
it till I'm done with it ten years
twenty years do you say here's something
that's interesting and I can't think of
any good ideas let me find something
else what drives your choices in
research so I think many times if I look
at these examples like the course I'm
unwell or deciding to work on prime
certificates or later on the property
testing and other things that I'm doing
now is these pseudo deterministic
algorithms which I haven't discussed so
these are algorithms where even though
they're randomized they arrive it with
high probability and a unique decision I
think in almost every single one of
these instances not all of them it was I
was either listening to a course I was
listening to a talk and somebody gave a
talk that sort of inspired me to think
of something else and then he did
intrigued me in or somebody challenged
me like in there whether is there
anything else to do in cryptography that
they challenged me Jerusalem and you
know I was so answering to a challenge
on the spot or I had a thought during a
talk so that doesn't sound very
scientific that's a method to find
research directions but it has been my
method right well it is curiosity driven
research right I mean not all
researchers are there to solve a
targeted problem in a targeted and
focused way so maybe this is you know it
tells us about the possibilities of just
letting your curiosity run wild right
even if the speaker is not intending to
ask you that question you interpreted
you got inspiration to solve some
question yes the solve some question may
be to define a question you know
immigration it's it's certainly the case
that once you define the question and
you have some initial ideas which are
captivating maybe it's a definition
maybe it's a solution
hopefully it's both these these fields
usually progress if there's you've
managed to get other people curious
right that certainly was the case for
promise encryption for zero-knowledge
for property testing even for primarily
based on elliptic curves it's not always
the case right and then you start
something you think it's fascinating you
write a few papers if there's no
continuation these things can sort of
die down
alright so actually tell us a little bit
about these kinds of experiences you try
something and it works and sometimes it
doesn't work did your expectations
always match we're there cases where you
did some work and you thought oh yeah
that's interesting but everybody liked
it a lot and or the other way around
where you wrote this paper and said
clearly this is my best work ever
maybe the best work in the last year and
nobody even paying attention have you
had experiences of either kind I think
that I've had more experiences where it
was a paper it was an idea that maybe I
loved my co-authors loved I almost all
my work is collaborative and but you
have no idea the kind of impact it's
going to have I think cryptography in
general as a field has had that kind of
luck or impact okay and also the work on
on hardness of approximation of klieg as
you know yeah it went very far who could
have predicted that right and so so
there have been up sides and you
willingly admitting to those well
they've been down the down one yeah of
course they've been down sides where you
know you write a paper you think it's
very interesting and then he doesn't get
into a conference all right we know
about a couple of those or maybe at
least one of those yeah that was the
famous zero knowledge paper write about
your feeling so zero knowledge in case
the viewer is not aware what was a paper
that was submitted three four five times
six times before it was finally accepted
yeah and is now definitely cited as the
one of the most impressive achievements
of that decade and here you are today
well at least you have the ability to be
happy about that eventual success of
their story so yeah tell exporters have
going on during those days this may
think so the thing is luckily for me
this was a paper together with Silvio
and it was eventually charlie also and
he's very stubborn so it doesn't really
care about anybody else's opinion I
certainly and so we kept on submitting
it and improving it and then eventually
got in and and and I remember that
facility and maybe by then for me to it
was like so obvious that finally these
morons understood the importance of this
work but no but seriously I've had works
that I have gotten rejected besides your
knowledge and some of them never got in
and then I I think it's interesting and
right that's it you know you put it on
your website and you go on I think that
being stubborn and helps okay but you
have to be really stubborn that's true
okay but I will tell you something that
you know we have these conferences talk
Fox conferences that it's harder and
harder to get papers they're they're
more technical than they ever used to be
and often it is exactly those papers
that are don't go with the grain but
they go against the grain they won't get
in right because the committee doesn't
understand or the committee is obliged
to take things which are more sort of
follow well trodden path
exactly and to address that we you know
we started new conferences right you
know one of conferences was developed
ECC which is in katara fee
rather than crypto another conference
was itcs right intervention in third
computer science where the idea is this
is the kind of work that these
conferences are supposed to take I think
often you start this way eventually it
becomes another conference that has its
own agenda right yeah yeah I think so so
certainly there seemed to be a lot of
you you've taken a lot of interest in
developing in I think TCC you mentioned
itcs you've been engaged in the creation
of these conferences setting them as an
agenda which is somewhat different and
seems to be part of the organic process
so do you enjoy this do you now that you
see how the conference's are doing now
do you think they do they're satisfying
their objectives or doesn't need to keep
fine-tuning this thing I think that they
are satisfying they're doing better than
what was done before I think you have to
keep on innovating okay you know I have
liked that we had this idea of
graduating bits where graduate students
can come and introduce themselves for a
few minutes right and session chair
rants where the session chair actually
gives a summary of the papers in the
conference but these things cannot stay
fixed because if they stay fixed they
they don't really serve and they don't
serve their function but I gotta say
that if one should admit that but often
my role in these you know evolutions or
in these new ventures
it comes from a place of frustration so
it's because I don't like the way things
are done right right it's a little bit
of a kind of an impulsive reaction
saying oh that's not the way to do it
let's do it differently let's shake it
up okay so I would love it if you came
from a place of peace right but I guess
maybe that's part of the passion that
drives research is also some frustration
and some angst so a patient with
impatience and so on collaborations tell
me a little bit about that you've had
wonderful collaborators and even more
impressive maybe not more impressive sir
pretty impressive set of students how do
you
you I mean how do you view research in
the collaborative environment how do you
research in with your students and so on
tell us a little bit about these
experiences of yours so these things
change over time obviously so early on
all of my collaborators were were you
know kids or people my age you know like
Silvio and Oded and AVI and McKibben or
so these were people who we were all
sort of graduating at the same time more
or less and it was part of our kind of
fight for our progression as AI
scientists to to talk about problems
together to go to dinner and talk about
problems to stay after dinner to talk
about problems he was like our life was
really working and collaborating so it
was it was research even though you are
all competing for the same attention
from the same people they are actually
collaborating with each other I think
yeah we are collaborating with each
other because we enjoy it because we can
do much better work when collaborating
and perhaps this group of people is just
very interactive and they don't like to
sit in a room alone and think but they
actually enjoy company and got a lot out
of this kind of collaboration in terms
of students early on I never worked with
my students but then as time progresses
you know each all these colleagues they
each go and they have their own not
exactly kingdom but they have their own
world
all right they go to different areas
they might even go geographically to
different locations and now if you want
to collaborate you collaborate with your
students okay sounds sounds very natural
and how has that been going with your
students I've had wonderful students
really incredible students so you've
been at at MIT
you've been Berkeley you're back here in
Berkeley Unified ceman anything which is
strikingly different about the different
places was it like nicer at Berkeley was
it myself
Weitzman was a nicer at MIT and see you
are so first of all I think that this
community our community of theoretical
peer science is extremely tight knit so
this style of research is done at
Berkeley and invites mine and MIT is
very similar in the sense of we value
the same type of results so we probably
would agree what a great result is what
an interesting result is I mean there's
individual differences but all together
this is the
community in terms of graduate students
you know I was a graduate student
Berkeley so it's hard for me to comment
on the grad students as a professor
thesis I just arrived okay
I think that at MIT I've been the
longest and have been exposed to the
most number of graduate students and
mathe has tons of graduate service the
quality is extremely high a they are
probably more technical then we were at
Berkeley at the time I don't know about
the typical Berkeley student now my
guess is it might still be the case that
it might be will draw these people who
were more intense okay
is there more technically inclined
invites fun you know again the numbers
are smaller the weather is better
you're comparing with MIT or but so let
me move on to aspects other than just
the research and the environment on the
research tell us a little bit about the
Turing award so how is the determinant
for the layperson what who decides on
the Turing award do you know anything I
assume that the Turing award is the
decided I mean I know it's not the Tony
Award is decided by a committee right
coming and you know there's first thing
that one has to understand about every
award is that in order to win it you
have to be nominated for it okay so
somebody sounds like you know this is
just a sight oh you don't have to add it
but I was ahead about an award committee
in Israel and you get one in chemistry
and one in physics and one in biology
and one math and they turned out that's
the four award winners were all men and
then I was this up or like how come no
women winners and I said and I said you
know it's well-known that in order to be
awarded you have to be nominated they
will win okay
so in any case you have to be nominated
right and I guess somebody nominated us
Sylvia and I wanted together and then I
guess there's a many or several
nominations and the award committee has
to make a decision and this is awarded
every year this is word of area and you
got it in 2012 2012 so
one interesting thing that I found about
the Ottoman was it definitely cited your
work and probablistic encryption on
zero-knowledge proves and those happen
when you were a graduate student it's a
little far away from in 2012 even you
got the award why this age difference
why this does the award like to wait for
a little while to read the results so do
you know so part of the reason why they
quoted that is because Sylvia and I sort
of went in different ways the work
problems he worked on in problems I
worked on were different after I worked
in more complexity like problems right
starting with the prime ality and then
going to the hardest approximation in
the different models where he were
working on destroy your computer you
worked on game theory so they excited
the things we did in comm it okay but
why wait because you don't know it's
really a test of time so the impact of
work it can only be determined after
many years after many years and in fact
even zero Nagy has had a lot more impact
maybe since 2012 than before 2012 right
sounds good so tell us about the award
so how did you find out that you're
getting the award yeah there was this
phone call by the head of the committee
he said that he he's calling from ACM
and he wants to tell me that I won the
Turing award together with Sylvia I said
they called from the ACM he said no no
I'm not buying yeah I was really happy
to win this award with Sylvia okay I
think that was probably a relief in some
sense it was probably the happiest thing
about winning this award is that we
wanted together because we've been
friends for so many years and with I
know this work together and it was uh it
was not gonna be a lonely experience you
know it's gonna be a joyous common
experience I can I can I can sympathize
with that how does it affect you I mean
so okay it's only been six years and
you've had a very long career before but
how does it affect your career do you
find that you're suddenly expected to do
different kinds of research now that
you've won the Turing award do you think
people pay more or less attention to you
when you say something
how is it easier to get funding for the
research that you want to do that's a
good question I think that first of all
people will say that it didn't impact in
they're lying mm-hmm
I've met a lot of people worn these
awards and you know even more famous
awards like a Nobel Prize and I'm sure
that it impacts everyone because the
kind of attention you get is
unprecedented and obviously you've got a
lot more commitments you supposed to you
invited to a lot more talks okay and
people expect you to write more letters
and that takes away time from other
things like doing research right that's
one thing do they pay more attention to
what you say I'm not sure okay
they pay different attention I'm not
sure they pay more attention what else
did you ask yeah I mean just funding for
it not funding no I did not find that at
all I don't think getting funding is
easier I don't think okay getting papers
accepted is easy
I think our field is completely pays no
attention oh okay I'm sorry to hear that
we want people when you're funding
looking at funding well we just want
everybody to get funded yes and when it
comes to papers we would like all the
good papers to be accepted no matter who
writes true assuming assuming that
people have good judgment when they
review work and that's a that's a that's
a subject for a different interview
right but we did bring that up in the
context of itcs before that it's always
we're always playing a game between our
tastes and you know starting new
directions versus closing our tol
direction something easier to evaluate
closing it an old direction then to
evaluate opening a new one and we're
taste is required or maybe foresight
right yeah
so you brought up the Nobel Prize and
you said oh you know it's an even more
famous price so now let me you know what
computer scientist citizenry is jumping
out in agony so we don't have a Nobel
Prize no computer scientist is gonna win
the Nobel Prize for being a computer
scientist they could win it for being an
economist they could win it for being a
physicist
not for I don't know Nobel Prize winners
in Berkeley get their own parking spot
do you get one well I pay for one for
one but you don't get your own placard
saying no this is a parking prizes
reserved for a Turing Award winner so is
this a way of systematically
discriminating against computer science
or even more broadly against all new
engineering why should an award that was
established a hundred years ago
determined the priorities of a
university or the research environment
or even the press today in terms of
determining what is important in good
research do you feel that this is this
is a challenge for computer science and
for all emerging fields I think a pure
sign is very special we've absolutely
changed the world I mean it's clear that
the impact of computer science in terms
of communication in terms of computation
in terms of you know the Internet
it's the banking the the shopping
there's no question whatsoever that we
have changed the world right and even
not even but people in fields like
chemistry and biology and physics will
do this amazing work about the origin of
life and the micro and the macro level
they all recognize that right and this
is change and therefore I think the
status of a whole prize is in our field
definitely is going to change this
culture it is changing because there's
no question about it even though I might
realize that I don't know I hope this
happened before you won the Turing award
or then after but the prize money went
from being a hundred thousand dollars to
a million to match the Nobel Prize that
was only recently fortunately it
happened unfortunately it happened after
so at least you know that's one
reasonable garage to have you know you
do not get here million dollars out of
getting a Turing Award as the Nobel
Prize winner this would have gotten you
know the story about my touring were
checked no so I was in the ACM banquet
in San Francisco and you know they call
these prizes and that the last price
they calls it in word and you go up to
the stage and they give you some kind of
plaque and you shake their hands and you
go and okay good the next day my sister
asks me she was in the bank but she said
so can I see the cheque I say what check
she said they gave you a check on the
stage I said no they didn't give me
anything they gave me a plaque they
definitely gave you an envelope I'm like
really
so I coast of Europe because he got a
check to it what the check was split you
know the prize was something and a half
and I said did you get a check and he
said yeah I got a check I already
deposited like more than hundred
thousand dollars and then I guess I left
it on the table oh my god sorry I called
ACM and I said listen now I feel a
little comfortable but I think I've
listed somebody maybe you know cleaning
stuff some other person at your table
maybe they took the check and cash it
seemed to have a higher regard for our
community all right so I'm talking about
communities actually what's going well
what's not going well we brought up the
issue of women in the field I mean women
getting awards in general
underrepresented minorities we
definitely seem to be lacking those
especially at the research level or not
lacking them and sheer number but
they're much much much fewer than we'd
like
so what is going on with our field is it
is the trajectory going up is it going
down I think that our field is composed
of a bunch of subfields in a particular
sub field of cryptography actually the
representation of women I think is good
in the sense at least that there's a
very well-known women who are doing
phenomenally well right in a fundamental
work there are jobs in very prestigious
universities and research labs and I
think there's also representation among
the graduate students of women in other
subfields it's not the case
my feeling is that had a lot to do with
the mentorship so in other words it
could be a woman
could be a man professor but some people
you see that they have women graduate
students and some don't so there must be
something that those who are having
women graduates are doing right or doing
different in any case so I think that
might be some thing to learn it's it's
it's clear it's not that somebody has
one woman and there's usually either a
bunch of women graduate students or not
so mentorship I think is very important
I think from what I understand the
number of women graduations is going
down it's not going up especially
relatively to other fields in computer
science with you specifically a I don't
know why okay maybe the opportunities in
industry are so are so good that people
are not going to graduate school right
okay so this seems to be like just
definitely a problem to be solved
do you have any when you said mentorship
is important in general as you know as a
mentor what are things that we could do
better
you think I mean these are there any
obvious things that people are either
not doing or doing wrong that you would
when you mentioned one example nominate
more women for awards there are other
things that you sort of think about or
think about well it's not only Awards
nominated for awards nominate for
fellowships other things is often when
you have a graduate stone in the
beginning of the of their career a not
always but sometimes you might have a
problem that you've partially worked out
and you tell the graduate student here
is this idea this is roughly what the
solution is and then they go and they
write it up or they actually solve it
completely and then they write it up and
the question is whether you would do
that
to the same extent for women than you
would for men because after all you want
the result to be written up and maybe
you some people believe that the men
will do a better job so being aware of
the fact that those type of nuggets or
give it good topics at the initial stage
that's right good a good topic to a
woman as much as a man I think people
should be aware of that
and that's something that needs requires
thinking purposefully okay it's not an
accidental okay good
and you've had a fair number of women
graduate students and so you probably
think about this a lot I think my woman
grasses have been so good that you maybe
you didn't know but uh maybe they give
you a nugget sir but I think I'm not
intimidating right and perhaps that's
another thing that again it's
generalizing where it's some men are
like that as well
probably women would be more intimidated
than men are in the beginning of the
career before they get confident because
they don't start from the point of view
like I know everything right so one has
to be a little careful about not to be
intimidating to some people that comes
naturally some people less all right
okay alright so I think we're about to
wrap up I want to ask you a little bit
about the future so tell us both about
your hopes and for the future of
computer science not just the community
where we definitely want to see better
diversity but in terms of research for
the field and also your own research
where do you want it to go next so in
terms of computer science and research
for the field obviously I think in we've
had been extremely successful as a
theory community to come up with ideas
that have somewhat changed they've been
they changed our field in the sense that
they have been rich and they had lots of
connections to mathematics more
generally and develop beautiful ideas
beautiful constructs
I like this evolution of a proof right
in addition to being beautifully
beautiful mathematically and complex
they've also had impact on applications
we've been living in a you know I guess
it's a few decades where as we said in
the beginning cryptography enabled
electronic commerce you know there's
this advent of cloud computing and we're
talking now about how to delegate our
computations to the cloud and get proofs
that the computation was done correctly
again a result of sort of the idea of
interactive proof where it's much easier
to verify proof than to actually perform
the computation that then you want to
prove
correct then another example is now with
machine learning everybody's talking
about about how we can use data in order
to come up with automated procedures
that make predictions that you kind of
learned from the data there's a question
about where is this they are coming from
how do we keep it private how do we do
machine learning on private data how do
we train models on private data how do
we classify private data so I think
cryptography will have a role to play I
think a significant role to play in how
machine learning is done in the future
in terms of my own you know my hope for
my own as you know I started being the
director here of the Simons Institute
okay it's a very different kind of
rolled and I've had in the past I've
been a researcher I've had students I
met postdocs written papers the role
here is to also have some sort of
scientific leadership which is
translates to enabling and pushing for
programs that do beautiful work
mathematically and also have a chance to
yield impact going forward
it also requires making sure that the
Institute is doing well from lots of
other perspective and will do so in
perpetuity I hope that I am successful
with this work and maybe even more than
everything I hope that in spite of the
fact that this is a new role and I still
manage to have some creative ideas and
have the creative juices flowing and
come up with new projects and new ideas
[Music]